Kennt ihr das, wenn die Haare
im Sommer blond werden?
Mario Wagner fragte uns,
warum Haare im Sommer heller werden.
Gute Frage. Besonders deutlich
ist dieser Effekt bei blonden
oder dunkelblonden Menschen
zu erkennen,
deren Haare im Sommer
richtig hell werden.
Aber selbst ich bekomme im Sommer
ein paar richtig hellbraune Haare.
Woran liegt das?
Schauen wir uns erst mal an,
was Haare eigentlich sind.
Haare bestehen zum größten Teil
aus Proteinen.
V.a. das Faserprotein Keratin.
Zwischen den Keratinfasern,
die den Hauptteil des Haares,
den Faserstamm ausmachen,
sitzen kleine Granulate aus Melanin.
Melanine sind Farbpigmente.
Es gibt zwei verschiedene Arten.
Es gibt Eumelanine,
das sind schwarze Pigmente,
und es gibt Phäomelanine,
das sind rote Pigmente.
Je nach Art, Zusammensetzung, Anzahl
und Größe dieser Melanin-Granulate,
der Pigment-Granulate, entstehen
die verschiedenen Haarfarben.
Schwarzhaarige und Brünette
haben mehr Eumelanin,
Blonde und Rothaarige
haben mehr Phäomelanin.
Viele Farbstoffe oder Pigmente
haben dasselbe chemische Prinzip.
Schauen wir uns mal
die Strukturen an.
Hier haben wir ein Eumelanin
und hier haben wir ein Chlorophyll.
Chlorophylle, das sind
die grünen Blattfarbstoffe.
Wir sehen 1., dass beide Strukturen
viele Doppelbindungen haben,
und wenn ihr genau hinschaut,
seht ihr 2.,
dass sich die Doppel-Einfach-
Bindungen immer abwechseln.
Und das nennt man
ein konjugiertes System.
Solche konjugierten Systeme zeichnen
sich oft durch kräftige Farben aus.
Wenn Sonnenlicht
auf ein konjugiertes System trifft,
wird es absorbiert,
d.h., aufgenommen.
So schützen uns die Melanine vor den
schädlichen Seiten des Sonnenlichts.
Darüber gehen sie
mit der Zeit kaputt.
Diesen Vorgang nennt man
Foto-Bleaching.
Die Melanine sterben,
um uns zu schützen.
Da die Phäomelanine
nicht so robust sind wie Eumelanine,
gehen bei hellen Haaren
die Pigmente schneller kaputt
und der Effekt ist besser sichtbar.
In der äußersten Haarschicht
sitzen übrigens keine Melanine.
Hier werden durch Sonnenlicht
v.a. Aminosäuren zerstört.
Bei hellem, wie auch bei dunklem Haar
entsteht Sommerspliss.
Unsere Hautpigmente,
das sind übrigens auch Melanine.
Warum wird dann unsere Haut
im Sommer dann dunkler?
Kurze Antwort: weil sie es kann.
Haarzellen sind tot.
Sie wachsen mit einer bestimmten
Anzahl an Melanin aus dem Kopf,
wenn diese durch
die Sonne zerstört werden,
können wir nur darauf warten,
dass neue nachwachsen.
Die Hautzellen leben aber.
Die können auf
das Sonnenlicht reagieren,
indem sie mehr Melanin produzieren,
um uns zu schützen.
Und so werden wir braun.
Die Melanine geben auf jeden Fall
ihr Bestes,
um euch flächendeckend zu schützen.
Doch manchmal ist alles was
dabei rauskommt: Sommersprossen.
Würde man eine Leiche
in die Sonne legen,
würde ihre Haut auch verbleichen.
Gut zu wissen.
Schön schlau.
Vielen Dank, Mario Wagner,
für die Frage.
Wenn ihr noch Fragen habt,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Dann kann ich sie vielleicht
auch mal beantworten.
Ansonsten sehen wir uns
nächste Woche. Bis dahin.
Bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)